foreign
[Music]
do you use Cas and find yourself wanting
a more repeatable way to automate the
process of managing your infrastructure
let's talk through how you can now
manage your Cas resources through
terraform managing Cloud resources isn't
super simple it can be hard to automate
the process and ensure the resource is
configured correctly and for some of you
using native tools available to manage
resources like those in Cas isn't even
an option because of your organization's
requirement to use terraform terraform
is an open source software tool that
lets you create and manage your
infrastructure such as CA service
resources through code instead of
manually this pattern is also known as
infrastructure as code IAC this comes
with a few really great benefits since
you're not managing your infrastructure
by hand this decreases the risk of error
because infrastructure changes can be
reviewed similar to code plus you can
track infrastructure changes through
Version Control and manage the
infrastructure on multiple Cloud
platforms now you can use Cas and and
manage CA pools Cas certificate
templates and certificates via terraform
and you don't need to do any workarounds
with the API or gcloud to activate your
subordinate Cas just use terraform end
to end let's review the steps to a
configuration that combines Cas and
terraform to create a CA pool with a
root CA and issue a certificate from
that created CA to use terraform with
Cas you only need a few simple commands
before getting started though make sure
you have the ca service admin IAM role
first you'll need to create a terraform
configuration file to do that you'll
create a new directory for the project
to live in in the new directory create a
main.tf file for the terraform
configuration
copy the terraform configuration into
that main.tf file there's documentation
Linked In the description that you can
use to help you write the infrastructure
you want
then you'll apply the configuration file
by first initializing terraform of the
directory you save the infrastructure
file in running the configuration file
with a terraform apply command and then
making sure the proposed changes look
good and agreeing to run it with a yes
command terraform will then execute this
under the hood and you can view this
later in Pantheon once you've set this
sub you can now take advantage of the
benefits that come with using terraform
to automate the management of your
resources if you're using Cas and want
to try managing your resources with
terraform or vice versa check out the
links in the description for more
details on how to make these two
products work together if you've been
enjoying using Cas and terraform
together leave us a comment and let us
know what you think thanks for watching
[Music]
foreign
[Music]